Monsieur le Préfet monsieur le Président
de la collectivité territoriale
messieurs les parlementaires
monsieur le Président de l'Association
des Maires mesdames Messieurs les élus
chers citoyennes Guyane mesdames et
messieurs nous voilà une nouvelle fois
réunis tous ensemble pour débattre
échanger et j'espère ardemment parvenir
à des décisions concrètes nous sommes
réunis pour évoquer la problématique de
l'insécurité si les congrès sur
l'évolution statutaire galvanis qu'une
petite partie de notre population ces
assis sur la sécurité ont le mérite de
parler à tous et pour cause tous les
habitants de ce territoire
malheureusement subissent les
conséquences de l'insécurité et certains
sécurité qui rend notre quotidien
invivable pour étayer mes propos
permettez-moi d'énoncer quelques
chiffres que certains d'entre vous
connaissent déjà l'an passé la Guyane a
connu 114 cambriolages de logements ni
le vol avec armes 1500 vols à la
roulotte 810 volts de véhicules et pour
finir près de 2000 vols sans violence
contre des personnes entre 2019 et 2020
notre département a connu 11,6 homicides
pour 100000 habitants contre 1,1
homicide en France hexagonale aussi
depuis le début de cette année les
autorités ont constaté 1,6 vols à mermé
par jour les derniers mois ont été
marqués par une recrudescence de faits
criminels graves qui serait la
conséquence directe de l'arrivée en
Guyane de factions brésiliennes les
forces de l'ordre sont très inquiets par
les activités de ces clans qui sévissent
en milieu urbain et se renforcent en
prison disons-le clairement la sécurité
c'est aussi leur paillage clandestins
qui met à mal notre environnement c'est
encore la pêche illégale qui appauvrit
une ressource halieutique c'est en outre
la prolifération des squats sous la
pression de l'immigration clandestine
loin de moi l'envie de dresser ici un
inventaire à la Prévert de cette délit
et crimes qui empoisonnent notre
quotidien mais je tiens à éviter chaque
Guyane à chacun d'entre nous à faire
notre examen de conscience
l'insécurité celle que nous déplorons se
nourrit aussi de nos petits arrangements
avec la loi quand nous acceptons
d'acheter un produit que nous savons
pertinemment issus d'un vol nous
entretenons cette insécurité quand nous
acceptons de faire appel à des ouvriers
non déclarés dans le seul but de gagner
quelques centaines d'euros nous
perpétuons le travail noir une autre
forme d'insécurité nous citoyens de ce
pays nous devons nous placer en première
ligne de ce combat contre l'insécurité
et ce n'est qu'alors maintenant que nous
pourrons exiger des efforts des autres
de l'État d'ailleurs en l'occurrence
avant ces assises d'aujourd'hui d'autres
avaient déjà travaillé sur un plan local
de sécurité en décembre 2016 à la veille
des événements de mars avril 2017 le
document produit à cette occasion
comporte 26 mesures pour lutter contre
la criminalité ces mesures sont six ans
plus tard toujours d'actualité un
constat qui prouve d'une part que ces
assises avaient vu juste et d'autre part
les mesures préconisées ont été peu ou
pas du tout appliqués il en va de même
de certaines recommandations prévues
dans le volet sécurité de l'accord de
Guyane j'aimerais donc penser à vous
même que nous entamions les travaux de
ce jour que nous disposons déjà dans
larges panel de mesure permettant de
s'attaquer à la sécurité aussi je
souhaiterais apporter d'emblée ma
première contribution dans le chapitre
de la prévention de la déont juvénile
vous le savez depuis 2016 je milite pour
une réintroduction du service militaire
dans les outre-mer le service militaire
avait une mission d'éducation de
stabilisation et de mixité sociale il y
a quelques jours j'ai vu visité le RSM
maths Saint-Laurent et j'ai eu le
plaisir de constater le formidable
résultat
obtenu par cette structure chaque année
des centaines de jeunes Guyane éprouvent
un emploi à l'issue d'une formation
qualifiante pour ma part nous devons
impérativement explorer toutes les
pistes qui permettront de sauver notre
jeunesse et lutter contre l'insécurité
pour conclure j'aimerais insister sur un
fait important la sécurité publique
demeure certes une mission régalienne
mais elle reste l'affaire de tous aussi
je remercie la collectivité territoriale
d'avoir organisé ces acides de la
sécurité qui doivent contribuer à
restaurer la sécurité et l'ordre public
résolument optimiste je veux croire que
nous sommes aujourd'hui suffisamment
mature pour travailler ensemble dans
l'intérêt de la Guyane et d'aiguillanais
il est temps chers collègues de mettre
nos différents de côté et
œuvrés pour le bien-être de nos
compatriotes je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté